Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
We've been talking a lot about juries, including
in the context of the Kyle Rittenhouse trial.
I told my story of serving on a jury last
week, and here is a caller who says, you know,
I think lawyers want incompetent
jurors. They don't want people who
think for themselves. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, it's it's Alex. I was just
listening to your episode about jury incompetence
and juries, and I'm actually a Ph.D. student
and I had a I have a thought about that. I feel
like it may be more of a matter of selection bias
in some sense than it is a matter of sheer
incompetence. I don't know about your opinion,
but at least in my experience, it seems like
most most lawyers try to select out the most
competent jurors intentionally. And so what
you're left with is those that are incompetent
rather than most people being incompetent. I don't
know what your thoughts are, but that's mine.
Speaker 1: So I still I continue to believe that
a large portion of people are just incompetent
at whatever they're doing. You go to, I
mean, listen, you go to most, I don't know,
retail stores or something like that. A lot of
incompetence. There you go to. You think in law,
everybody's competent. I've had some pretty bad
experiences with it, with incompetent lawyers.
I think that there's two things going on. I think
there are a lot of incompetent people in general
in the population. But I do think that it may
not be. I spoke to a couple of lawyers about
this who who do jury trials, and they've said it's
not that we want incompetent people on the jury,
but we want what they described
as simpler people. Now that
that's pejorative in a sense. But what they
mean by it and they've explained it to me is.
If you have a simpler jury. You can
Speaker 3: more
Speaker 1: easily predict how
the jury will react to certain
presentations, either of evidence of testimony,
cetera. And that's why in big jury trials
like, you know, murder trials, et cetera, you may
have a tendency not towards incompetence per say,
but towards folks who are more likely to react
in a predictable way, rather than quote thinking
for themselves in ways that may be unpredictable
for both the prosecutors and the defense. That's
what lawyers have told me. All right, we've got a
great bonus show for you today. We will talk about
the horrible surge in highway deaths we're
going to talk about. Sugar has been blamed a
lot for obesity, but sugar consumption is down and
obesity continues up. What can we make of this?
And we will talk about the horrible tragedy at
this Travis Scott concert. We're going to talk
about crowd control and a lot of other things,
all on today's bonus show. Sign up at Join
Pacman dot com and you will get instant access
Unidentified: to today's folks.